it was actually a church where I first  gave my money with somebody  church and in New Haven asked me if I  would give I think ten thousand dollars  for a capital campaign and I agreed but  he was a friend and that started me  thinking and then afterwards when I  moved to Seattle and to direct the  seattle art museum but when i became a  part of the gates family the whole  culture of philanthropy I mean it just  even though we all give separately but  it becomes certainly ingrained than you  right that aspect has been recurrent a  recurrent theme in the with our gas in  which you asked Julian Bond how did you  start you ask Harry Belafonte how you  start and you guys don't live in ski how  you start and they said because someone  asked me do you think that was a  catalytic moment absolutely and you know  thinking back on it that's when I  personally first be gay became  interested in giving and realized that  what what a gift to me it was